hey what is up everybody it's annamac
here for anime uproar and today
i will be breaking down the very latest
developments in black
clover and man there is so much to talk
about
an incredible secret weapon has just
been revealed
yami's life seems to be hanging by a
thread
asta is stronger than ever before
and the epic final showdown of this war
arc
is about to begin let's get into it
if you enjoy our content here on the
channel you want to see more black lower
videos
please leave a like and comment it
really does help
you might think it doesn't matter but
actually every like and comment
tells youtube to promote this video to
more people so yeah just by liking and
commenting you're actually helping the
channel and of course if you're new or
maybe you just haven't subscribed yet
make this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on
all notifications finally this video
will of course contain
black clover manga spoilers so please
proceed with caution
you have been warned the latest
installment of the story starts out in
the castle
inside the spade kingdom capital the
same castle that knocked had infiltrated
as a spy
earlier on in the story it turns out
that morris is here
the magic scholar from the diamond
kingdom who was the one experimenting on
mars and
fauna and who was apparently secretly
controlling the entire diamond kingdom
from behind the scenes
it seems that mars threw morris out of
the diamond kingdom so now he is working
with the dark
triad and he is helping dante recover
from the injuries that he had sustained
during his battle with asta
and yami according to morris dante is
doing just fine
and when he recovers he will be stronger
than ever
now remember that morris is the guy who
was able to fuse
two separate grimoires together and he
is also the guy who was able to embed
magic stones into mars so this guy
is not someone that we should
underestimate clearly his magical
knowledge is vast
and very very dangerous also he's
obviously not a nice guy
guided by a strong moral code so he
could prove to be a big challenge
for our heroes in fact morris says that
he was the one who created the mobile
fortress
condello that fortress from chapter 229
that was powered through the forcible
draining of mana from the spade kingdom
citizens so it seems that morris has
been working with the spade kingdom for
quite a while
now we know that the dark triad attacked
and subjugated the diamond kingdom
so my first thought was that maybe
morris was being forced to help the dark
triad
but then as i said morris confirms that
he was ousted from the diamond kingdom
because of mars
and he seems to be helping the dark
triad willingly in fact he seems
grateful for the opportunity
morris definitely looks like the type of
guy who would betray his own kingdom if
he got a better opportunity from a rival
kingdom so it seems like that's what
happened
but our boy lotus is there too and
knowing lotus and how self-interested of
a person he is
it's pretty safe to say that lotus isn't
here because he's a big fan
of the dark triad there must be
something
in it for him and i can't wait to find
out what he is really up to
lotus would never get involved in
something dangerous unless there was a
very good reason
from his point of view so i wonder what
that reason
is meanwhile dante is hanging out in a
medical machine that looks like
something right out of dragon ball z
and we can see that he is conscious he
is also excited at the prospect of
fighting asta again
and you just know that as crazy as dante
has been up this point he is about to
get
even crazier we then realize that there
is something
else inside this spade kingdom
laboratory
something unbelievable the body
of some unknown devil appears to be
frozen
inside this laboratory and it seems that
the devil's body is an important part of
the dark triads plan
morris says that all the preparations
are going smoothly and lotus agrees
but lotus also appears to be very uneasy
about that frozen devil although he
doesn't say it
out loud and again lotus is not the type
of guy to risk his own life for the
rulers of some foreign kingdom like the
dark triad
i really do think that lotus has his own
agenda here
an agenda that isn't necessarily tied to
either morris
or the dark triad but we'll have to wait
and see
now this frozen devil is likely another
direct
reference to dante's inferno those of
you who saw my theory video about the
final villain in black clover
know that in dante's inferno the devil
whose name is lucifer
is frozen on the lowest circle of hell
but still
this doesn't appear to be the body of
lucifer dante's devil from black clover
unless this image is misleading the
number of wings
is clearly wrong and if lucifer's body
is on the lowest level
of the tree of clifford then what would
the body be doing here
in the lab so is this the body of the
devil who is
on the very top of the tree of clifforth
and is he maybe going to remain frozen
until the tree of cliphoth is opened
or is this devil a separate being
altogether
this frozen devil could definitely be
some sort of secret weapon that the dark
triad
plans to use to complete their master
plan
maybe morris plans to use this devil's
body for some sort of sick experiment
i'm not sure what exactly this devil is
doing here or where it came from
but the fact that we got to see him now
is definitely significant
this devil will play some sort of
important role in the future
but we just can't be sure what that role
will be
at least not yet we then see a brief
glimpse of
yami's face or at least the bottom half
of his face
before we get a look at what appears to
be the tree of cliff
off in the making let me tell you this
looks extremely creepy
and ominous it's like something right
out of stranger things
or i guess right out of dante's inferno
i am definitely worried for my boy yami
at this point things are not looking
good
and yeah william is cool i guess but
yami is one of my favorite characters
in the entire story so you know william
i wish you luck bro but if i had to
choose between you and yami
i would choose yami anyway the focus of
the chapter then switches back to asta
and liba's fight against knocked but
if you were hoping to get a detailed
look at asta's new
devil union form and his new powers and
abilities you're out of luck
at least for now the story picks up at
the point at which asta and liba have
already been separated again
so they are no longer in that devil
union form
however noct says that he was just
defeated
apparently the battle already happened
off screen
oh man what a tease and austin liba beat
knocked like wait what you're really
just gonna do us like that tabata
after asta and liba getting absolutely
pimp slapped by knocked for a bunch of
chapters
they now suddenly managed to defeat him
and we didn't even see it
oh i guess tabata wants us to wait until
the real battle against the dark triad
begins before he reveals asta's new
form and new powers which yeah it makes
sense but damn
what a tease interestingly though after
being defeated by astan liba
noct says to himself that once it
reaches its true potential
anti-magic will become the strongest
attribute of all
which is really crazy when you think
about it if anyone knows about strength
and the potential of devil magic
it's knocked so the fact that he
believes that anti-magic has the
potential to become the strongest
is a big deal osta thinks that the
training is now over so he tells noc
that they need to hurry and go and save
yami
but knox says no austen liba did manage
to unlock the devil union mode
but they were only able to hold it
together for a brief period of time
they still haven't perfected this devil
union and if they get caught
inside enemy territory and they can't
hold the union together for long enough
they will be killed so this training
isn't as easy as asta thought it would
be
he and leban must still train even
harder and they must learn to perfect
their devil union before the real battle
begins
noct then reveals something important to
asta
it turns out that even though knocked
previously claimed that he hates the
black bulls and even though he claimed
to have been away from black bull's hq
for years
he was actually using his shadow magic
to keep an eye
on all of the black bulls including asta
knocked tells asta that he knows that
asta was born without magic and he knows
how
asta came into contact with the grimoire
that was possessed by a devil who turned
out to be liba and now
after getting to know asta noct has
faith in asta
and he believes that asta can in fact do
what it takes
to save yami this is a big deal because
when they first met
noct was not so kind to asta and then
after these brief words of encouragement
noct says that he will leave gimodello
with asta and liba
presumably so they can keep training
with him while knocked
takes care of all the other preparations
for the planned infiltration of the
spade kingdom
asta and liba will have to complete
their training and then join the others
as soon as possible austin liebe are
both determined to get the job done
although gimodello seems pretty worried
by the prospect of having to fight
against
anti-magic clearly anti-magic is a big
threat
even for devils this chapter ends with a
shot of the special clover kingdom unit
as it prepares to take part in the
infiltration
there are 13 shadows of people that we
see overall
but only 9 of the individual people are
actually revealed
at this time we see rill who apparently
got a haircut charlotte
dorothy jack noesel fugolian langris and
yuno
and all of that makes sense these are
some of the strongest mages in the
entire country
magic knight captains and vice captains
they really are the best of the best
but then standing in the back just
behind jack
we see someone else we see none other
than the one
the only seque d bronzaza
why why on earth would tabata include
seke
in this group does he not realize that
if sekei is going then all the other
mages are not even necessary because
demon king seki would annihilate the
entire dark triad by himself without
even trying
damn man i was really enjoying this arc
so far but it's about to get real boring
once hakai shin seki
takes out the bad guys in like four
seconds and that's it ark
over seriously though including sekke is
kind of a flex by tabata
not gonna lie he is definitely giving
the fan base exactly what we want
more second memes and i for one am 100
on board also maybe seke has been
promoted to vice captain of the green
mantis squad
so that's why he was invited if so props
to my boy seki
i mean he could have easily taken over
his captain but out of respect for jack
he settled for just vice captain what a
kind and benevolent ruler
our lord seki has become and lord sekei
is the true secret weapon in black
clover he is the real wild card
of this arc and i can't wait to see what
he is about to do
but this last scene really got me
wondering
since we see 13 shadows there but only
nine people are revealed
who are the other four who are the ones
that we still haven't seen
is knocked already there with them like
is this happening in the future
or are they still waiting on knocked is
mero leona there
is julius there is zora there is magna
there
definitely let me know who you guys
think made the cut for this
special squad also what are your
thoughts on that
frozen devil who is he and how does he
fit
into the dark triads plans don't forget
to leave your thoughts
down in the comments below if you
enjoyed this video and you want to see
more blacklover content right here on
the channel please leave that like
it really does help and if you're new to
animeopro or you haven't subscribed
make this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on
all notifications you really have to go
through the trouble of hitting that bell
and then selecting the option that says
all if you don't do that you're still
going to miss a ton of our videos even
if you are subscribed it's annoying but
that's how youtube works
you can also hit me up on twitter and
instagram
at animeopror i want to give a big thank
you to all of our anime uproar
patrons for making videos like this one
possible a special thank you to
alpha sigma a disciple of lord twiggle
himself
and i can't forget all of our the one
tier patrons
including ingrata the world acquired
respect
liam thompson pate heffa rithyanyx
emperor otaku thomas jones spidey life
canal
baked buddhist tungsten tarcus and denki
kaminari and finally thanks to our pro
hero tier patrons including the one and
only gilgamesh steelers
angel cruz anatoly kazatsky cricket xp
joe stanton rothlin deora very gucci
jessica calefon
alicia octor hinokami and water bonnie
parks the red-haired raven florian joy
and garcia mcshamus
jack watches anime amanda c deadly saint
high school dxd73
matthew cruz and anthony schreiber if
you enjoy our videos and you feel that
they provide value for you consider
supporting us
on patreon even a single dollar will
give you access to our patreon exclusive
discord
and your name will appear in our videos
along with these
legendary people as always thank you
guys so much for watching
and until next time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you